there's an interesting question about
leaders
i've talked to vitalik buter and i'll
probably talk to him again soon
he's the one of the leaders maybe one of
the faces of the ethereum project
and it's interesting you have uh satoshi
nakamoto
who's the face of bitcoin i guess but
he's faceless
he she they
it does seem like in our whatever it is
maybe it's 20th century
maybe it's mecha valley and thinking but
we seek leaders leaders have value linus
torvald
the leader of uh of linux
um the open source development a lot i
mean there's no
it's not it's not that the leadership is
sort of dogmatic
but it's inspiring and it's also
powerful in that through leaders we
propagate the vision
like the the vision of the project is
more stable
maybe not the details but the vision and
so do you think there's value
to because we're there's a tension
between decentralization and leadership
like in visionary yes what do you make
of that tension
okay so i really believe that if it's a
another good question i think of it you
know
i really believe in the power of
emotions i think the emotion i have a
creative impulse of
everybody else and very very far is very
easy for a leader to be
a a physical person a real being
and that interprets our emotions and by
the way
this emotion needs to resonate and what
is good is that the
the more intimate our emotions are the
more universal they are
paradoxically more personal the more
everybody else yes somehow magically
agrees and feels
a bit of the same and so and it's very
important
to have a leader in the initial phase
that
generates out or nothing something that
is important leadership
but then the true tested leadership is
to disappear
after you led the community so in my
opinion the quintessential leader
in my uh
according to my vision is george
washington it served for one term
for another term and then all of a
sudden he retired
became a private citizen and 200 and
change
years later we still are we send the
facts but we have done a lot of things
right
and we have been able to evolve that to
me is success in leadership
but instead you contrast our experiment
with a lot of experiments i've done so
much
so well that i want another four years
and why should i be
only a four and i have another eight and
why should be another eight
give me sixteen i will fix all your
problem and now then
is the type in my opinion of failed
leadership
leadership or to be really lead ignite
and disappear and if you don't disappear
the system is going to die
with you and it's not a good idea for
everybody else
you